hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 american science fiction and
thriller movie called the unhealer
the movie begins with an old and fragile
man reverend pfluger who is doing some
kind of ritual of the indian burial
grounds
suddenly a lightning bolt strikes which
causes him to be thrown away with a
smile on his face he then goes away
indicating that the ritual succeeds
scene moves to a team called kelly who
suffers from an eating disorder called
pica he rather chooses to eat the
styrofoam cup than the ramen inside
shortly afterwards his bully classmates
led by nelson confront him they even
call him a trash boy dominique comes to
defend him however the boys ignore her
and start cramming him into a trash bin
while one of them records the action
after the boys run away dom offers him a
ride to school with sarah's car but
rejected by sarah
long story short kelly arrives at school
while eating his styrofoam cup
at school all of his friends are
laughing at him because the video has
spread among the students
after school kelly returns home and
meets his mom bernice
while helping her he picks up the
receipt and eats it on the other side
dom's mom thinks she is falling in love
with nelson but dom denies it because
it's impossible for her to have a crush
on a bully
she is pissed when her mom also thinks
that kelly is a weird boy
turns out that dom has had feelings
towards kelly since junior high school
scene moves to red elk a native american
who just figures out that the hidden
power kept in the burial site has been
stolen the eating disorder has brought a
negative impact towards kelly's body
he is weak and undernourished the doctor
cannot help him because he thinks it is
a psychological issue
fluger finally appears again this time
he claims to have a superpower that can
heal any illness
he manages to cure an old woman's
disease just by touching her which
shocks all the people nearby bernice
sees the miracle and asks for the old
man's help to heal kelly he agrees to do
so
suddenly red elk confronts fluger and
slaps him but the pain is transferred to
him instead
the old man feels no pain at all
red elf then reveals that the healing
power does not belong to him and it will
destroy him eventually he urges fluger
to give the power back but the cocky old
man refuses and goes away bernice
returns home ringing pflueger with him
kelly's condition is getting worse and
he immediately starts the healing
process but it seems that the old man
suddenly can feel kelly's pain
feeling uncomfortable he takes a short
break and consumes his magic powder he
then continues treating the poor young
boy however pfluger feels an
excruciating pain when touching kelly
causing the cigarette to fall down to
kelly's chest
he tries to resist the pain but he
suddenly falls and dies on the spot a
few moments later kelly magically
becomes more energetic and says that he
is hungry
long story short the police arrive in
one of them adler figures out that the
burn hole in the chest caused by the
cigarette earlier has vanished which
makes kelly's mom confused the next day
kelly accidentally cuts his finger while
fixing his bike but a miracle happens as
the wound magically disappears he then
tries to explain it to his mom but she
doesn't believe him
while on his way to school kelly meets
dom and sarah who are surprised to see
him in better shape and more healthy
than yesterday
after they leave reed nelson's brother
confronts kelly and starts punching him
but the pain is transferred to reed
while kelly feels no pain at all
he even attempts to hurt him with a
block of wood but fails
realizing that he can't beat the new
version of kelly reed runs away with
bruises all over his face
later that night gus reed's father and
football coach at their school comes to
confirm what happened to his son
kelly states that reed hurt himself gus
doesn't believe him but bernice forces
them to leave kelly finally reveals his
pain transferring ability to his mom
saying that nobody will ever hurt them
again
he even can withstand the cigarette
lighter the next day while in the
classroom kelly starts his wild
imagination picturing himself with dom
who becomes naughty
sarah who hates kelly in the real world
also joins them
surprisingly the sensation from the
imagination also affects dom and sarah
in real life causing sarah to scream in
pleasure at a campfire event the boys
try to disturb and seduce dom but this
time kelly appears and defends her they
almost engage in a fight luckily gus
comes and separates them while on his
way home kelly is spotted by the boys
and they attempt to scare him kelly
panics and tries to avoid the car
however he falls off her bike and the
car accidentally hits him but kelly is
not injured at all in the car driver
brat receives all the pain instead which
kills him instantly the remaining boys
are terrified when they see kelly as ok
and run away from the scene
not long after the police and the others
arrive at the crime scene where kelly
explains the chronology to his mom and
reveals his power to dom
on the other side nelson states that
kelly purposely pulled himself in front
of the car and brad was killed by the
airbag
kelly's relationship with dom is getting
better and better
kelly even asked dom out for a date
however the boys want revenge and plan a
strategy
at work red elk confronts kelly and
questions him how he could survive from
the car crash
he then reveals that fluger helped him
and knows nothing about the power
kelly then returns home where he finds
his mom is not in a great condition he
then goes out to buy an aspirin
outside the house the boys have been
waiting and think that it was bernice
who went away
they execute the plan and start pulling
the container's foundation with gus's
car causing it to fall down and break
the gas pipe bernice tries to escape but
the house suddenly explodes because of
gas leaks killing her instantly kelly
returns home and is very shocked when he
finds out her mother has passed away he
is brought to the hospital where adler
appears and tries to help him
suddenly red l confronts adler telling
him that kelly is possessing their
ancestors power and asks him to help him
retrieve the power
after his mom's funeral kelly goes to
fluger's grave and accidentally eats a
vine causing him to suffer and vomit
sarah witnesses the event and goes away
adler attempts to help the poor kid by
offering him to move to a foster family
while on their way adler states that the
container supports were purposely pulled
out and his mom's death wasn't an
accident a few moments later nelson and
the boys who are on their way to the
river meet kelly and mock him from their
car
since then kelly concludes that they are
the perpetrators behind his mother's
death he then jumps out from the
sheriff's car
kelly eventually spots the boys who are
having fun at the riverside tucker jumps
into the water and the others start
throwing him with rocks
kelly sneaks in and takes tucker's shirt
as usual he eats it before using it to
strangle himself
tucker immediately feels the effect
causing him to drown
nelson tries to help him while reed is
running away but it is too late kelly
then shows up and attempts to do the
same thing but adler arrives on time and
kelly flees
tucker is dead and adler starts
interrogating the boys
they tell him that it was kelly's fault
having heard about tucker's incident dom
urges him to stop killing people she
suggests him to make them confess
instead the next day in chemistry class
kelly shows up late and makes fun of
tony forcing him to admit that he is his
mom's killer tony is furious and pours
chemical solution towards kelly's face
however it burns tony's face instead and
instantly kills him the girls are very
shocked and kelly runs away while adler
arrives at the class
that night sarah approaches nelson
telling him what she saw earlier at the
funeral
they go to the fluger's grave and
harvest the plant that caused kelly to
suffer earlier
nelson prepares the concoction and
stores it in an extinguisher the next
day adler finds the chains that were
used to pull out kelly's container
supports in gus's pickup he then
immediately confronts the boys and
forces them to confess but they keep
lying saying that they know nothing on
the other side kelly sneaks in and
steals a power drill from nelson's car
he then suddenly shows up with his
weapon while nelson is also ready with
his extinguisher kelly starts drilling
his own knee causing nelson to feel the
exact pain
adler finally believes what red elk said
earlier while dom comes and tells him to
stop
nelson attempts to shoot him with the
liquid which weakens kelly gus takes
advantage of this and tries to shoot him
with adler's gun but the bullet kills
him and nelson instead
dom is disappointed with kelly and begs
him to give the power back to red elk he
then reluctantly agrees
long story short red elk and alder begin
the power transferring ceremony in front
of fluger's grave however the power has
been the part of him and they have no
choice but to kill him
dom helps kelly to escape but the police
shoot them causing them to be thrown
away to fluger's grave he can't save
kelly and blames the old man for giving
him such power
the enraged kelly then eats fluger's
heart and suddenly dies
at the end of the movie in the ambulance
dom suddenly comes back to life
indicating that the power has been
transferred to her
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching